die flagge die lage ist schräg das ist
wir sind hier liegen versinken in der
kutsche ja ich wollte endlich mal
jemanden haben der auch wirklich liegt
wenn ich die frage stellen und in laage
schreck die lage recht schräg auf jeden
fall
du hast du dass sie uns hier eingeladen
um so ein bisschen ein psychospiel trieb
auszuleben haben genau erst uns hier
genetik auf der couch so genau
ok und machst uns wird dieser position
hier gefüge schafften schossen
vertrauensvolles umfeld entspannung und
so weiter das ist die wahrheit liegt
damit er über beef redet wir den
ältesten und bekanntesten rapper damit
wenn die entsprechenden werte haben und
so funktioniert der winter bitte so
funktioniert das ja wir bedienen das ja
auch wenn ich eigentlich wie ist die
lage ihr seid auf 1 in den charts wenn
in dem moment wo wir dieses interview
führen das ist ja immer noch glaubt
schon ich weiß also jedes heute heute
noch oder heute noch und dann nicht mehr
nur weil du nicht noch mal auf 1 werden
wir wundes sein vielleicht noch ein
schauen wir mal was cool soll sagen es
schön auf 1 zu sein
gute sache aber gar nicht so wichtig wie
der ein oder andere vielleicht glaubt
und habt ihr das war das geplant weil
ich sage mir ich habe im letzten jahr
schon gehört wo genetik das wird der
hammer ich hab mir damals euer album the
circus auch angehört und das aber das
war ja nie in den charts von daher wie
kann man an
ja wir waren in österreich glaubt platz
56 oder irgendwie sowas weil weil online
so gut lief online bauen wir auf eins in
deutschland aber das album war ja nicht
relevant wir sind ja ganz schön die
läden gegangen das heißt man konnte
damit gar nicht starten
egal wieviel einheiten wir verkauft
hätten so okay aber ich war es gibt ja
ganz viele leute die versuchen irgendwie
auf die eins bekommen wenige schaffen
ist euer titel liebt oder lass es
mit sido läuft im radio rauf und runter
auch das ist ja nicht leicht
hinzukriegen
also was was wert ist das ein besonderes
gefühl dass ihr für eure musik habt oder
was ist das was klappt also erst mal
haben wir einen starken partner mit half
mit das ist einfach so dass jeder der
sich mit deutschland beschäftigt weiß
das und dann machen wir halt einfach so
gut wie wir können musik und hoffen dass
es vielen leuten gefällt und scheinbar
gefällt ausreichend vielen leuten dass
man damit auch auf 1 gehen kann
aber wir haben jetzt kein besonderes
konzept um im radio zu laufen irgendwie
sowas so also wir denken nicht darüber
nach ob wir einen song machen der ins
radio kommt oder so das ist einer der
songs vom album gewesen und der war
radiotauglich und dann hat man es
versucht und es hat geklappt haben das
angenommen und spielen das jetzt und das
freut einen natürlich aber hätten sie es
jetzt abgelehnt dann hätten sie es halt
abgelehnt mein gott so das hat bestimmt
zu den verkaufszahlen beigetragen aber
ja keine ahnung ist jetzt kein wert an
sich so irgendwie im radio zu laufen so
wir machen die musik die wir machen und
fertig wenn es dann im radio läuft läuft
es auf 1 geht geht's auf eins wenn es
nicht auf 1 geht jetzt nicht auf 1 egal
ob nein also gut wenn wir sagen wir
natürlich jetzt ganz egal wer auch
gelogen
natürlich ist es eine genugtuung wenn
man gearbeitet hatte sich angestrengt
hat
und das beste rausholen wollte und dann
kriegt man das in zahlen sozusagen
zurück aber ganz ehrlich so charts ist
eine sache die wird relativ bewertet und
es kann halt einfach auch sein dass wenn
jetzt irgendeinen krasser deutscher
schlager rauskommt grad ja dann schafft
man halt die einst nicht aber deshalb
ist das album nicht schlechter also ich
weiß nicht so das hat für uns nicht die
bedeutung die das das glaubt ihm
manchmal gefühle für die leute von außen
hat das mehr bedeutung als für uns
selbst ist natürlich cool auf jeden fall
wir freuen uns auch und so aber keine
ahnung das album der genauso gut gewesen
wenn wir auf 10 gegangen
dass das gleiche album gewesen werden
die gleiche marke gemacht wir hätten
vielleicht ist genau so viel verkauft
nur hätten halt andere noch mehr
verkauft sodann keine ahnung deswegen
weiß ich nicht was ich dazu so groß
sagen soll
wir freuen uns und fertig ok ihr habt
mit 13 angefangen war gab es im moment
wo sich viele viele rappen mit 13 gab es
irgendwo moment wo ihr gesehen habt hey
das also wir haben was drauf das ändert
sich
und was ist da passiert irgendwo moment
auch wohl gesagt okay ich mach' jetzt
keine ausbildung ein studium keinen das
oder das oder machen sie alles was ja
auch noch nicht fertig mit seinem
studium hat ein bachelor und würden
willst du denn als architekt
weiterarbeiten oder was für eine rolle
spielt das für euch dieser die berufe
dann die ihr habt ihr zwei mal schauen
also wie es jetzt läuft mit der mutter
aber rein theoretisch besser als plan b
wenn nichts mehr geht habe ich meinen
beruf okay ihr würdet auch jedem
empfehlen sich nicht auf zufall auf
jeden fall
ich würde es auch nicht ja weil es kein
kann sich plan
dass es so kommt auch nicht mit der
einst canales nicht planen es ist
einfach gehört auch glück dazu nicht
jeder der was kann geschadet jetzt auf 1
oder so es ist einfach passiert
es gibt auch krasse künstler die super
gute musik machen und die kommen
überhaupt nicht in die charts die sind
gar nicht relevant
keine ahnung so wenn man jetzt erstmal
ausweitet und in anderen musik sport und
guckt und so weiter
dann gibts sowieso viel gute musik im
jazzbereich und so weiter und die zarten
ja auch nicht hoch sollte machten aber
keine schlechte musik deshalb so also
keine ahnung das kann man halt einfach
wenn man mehrere standbeine haben kann
sollte man auf jeden fall mehrgleisig
fahren weil es geht der ländliche raum
kann ich davon leben oder kann ich nicht
aber gibt es irgendeine perspektive oder
gar kein klar aber es sollte auch immer
so
mir wäre jetzt nur musik auch zu wenig
in meinem leben noch andere sachen ich
bin vielseitig interessiert und mein
interesse geht ihm viel zu viele
richtungen als dass ich mich nur mit
einer sache beschäftigen können
aber muss man wenn man gute musik machen
will sich nicht einmal 100 damit
beschäftigen oder braucht man im
gegenteil auf rein ich glaube im
gegenteil dass man sich überhaupt nicht
nur mit musik beschäftigen darf sondern
man muss ja auch irgendwie inspiration
man braucht ja irgendwie auch input wenn
man so viel output gibt sozusagen und
schöpferisch tätig ist dann braucht man
ja irgendwo muss man sich das ja wieder
reinholen und das holt man sich
typischerweise aber eben genau in ganz
anderen bereichen keine ahnung das kann
seinen film zu sehen andere musik zu
hören nicht hip hop was zu lesen sich
mit menschen zu unterhalten zu reisen
oder sowas keine ahnung gibt es gibt so
viel dass einem da helfen kann und keine
ahnung das leben ist nur eine sache
das leben ist nur eine sache egal für
wen und für uns eben auch nicht so
deswegen beschäftigen wir uns einfach
die schnur mit musik und auch mit vielen
anderen sachen wodurch habt ihr euch da
inspirieren lassen
keine ahnung bestimmt wieder fängt damit
an dass zig produziert und dann ist es
oft so dass ich gar nicht mehr viel
machen muss sondern dass wir fahren
einfach den gleichen film und dann ist
das ding da und ich weiß genau irgendwie
was jetzt kommt und keine ahnung aber
natürlich so ich habe 100 millionen
tracks im kopf von rappern oder anderen
künstlern eben auch aus dem nicht hip
hop bereich
das kann ich nicht oft genug wiederholen
die mir gefallen die mich inspirieren an
dich denken muss und ich denke da sind
geiles thema das will ich auch
aufarbeiten das will ich auch benutzen
und macht halt auf meine art natürlich
weil man hat natürlich immer quelle der
inspiration und man will natürlich nicht
genau das gleiche machen sondern hat
einen eigenen ansatz wie man daran geht
und ich kann es gar nicht sagen konkret
welcher trecker treck aber bestimmt
keine ahnung so von irgendeinem casino
hatte das rock master oder so auf jeden
fall aber ist es nicht so wenn man so
wenn man so viele musik oder andere
musik im kopf hat dass man nicht immer
gefahr läuft oder ist aber man hat eine
idee und dekane verdammt gab es schon
oder
da bin ich zu dich daran wie kommt man
auf den eigenen weg von der melodie
werden von der melodie von alles kann
auch der beat sein
ja also es wird passieren dass
das dann am ende komplett gleich klingt
das ist dann sowieso irgendwann selbst
wenn ich es versuchen würde das komplett
nachzubauen klingt am ende anders hat
dann seine eigene note sozusagen also es
ist es geht gar nicht und ich versuche
auch nicht irgendwelche dinge
nachzubauen oder so aber ja schon weit 1
also hast einen song oder denkst du okay
ich will jetzt nicht die töne und die
geschwindigkeit und die lyrics oder so
sondern denkt okay
irgendwie dass das transportiert was und
ich will auch das transportieren und
dann versucht man halt sozusagen etwas
eigenes zu machen und hat dann im
idealfall hat natürlich einfach ein
eigenes produkt was aber die eine
ähnliche energie hat einfach also mal
versucht einfach die energie sozusagen
zu nehmen und zu was heißt zu
reproduzieren einfach noch mal für sich
zu nutzen nur zu transportieren einfach
ihr habt gerade von gleichklang
gesprochen ihr kennt euch schon seit dem
13 lebensjahren ist das wichtig dass ihr
schon so lange zusammen das macht ich
denke schon
ich glaube das macht einen großteil
dessen aus was am ende herauskommt weil
wir einfach sehr eingespielt sind und
natürlich sind wir zwei verschiedene
menschen aber so ich sag mal was die
musik angeht und die gemeinsame vision
hat sich das einfach schon sehr lange
gemeinsam entwickelt naja und genetik
ist unsere gemeinsame vision und die dem
die musik die wir machen und das lebt
natürlich schon sehr lange nebeneinander
her und einer hat vom anderen gelernt
und lernt immer noch vom anderen und
deswegen würde ich schon sagen dass du
diese kombination dieses vertrauen was
zwischen uns besteht und auch die die ja
die interessen und das das gemeinsame
uhr sozusagen die gemeinsame vorliebe
für eine gewisse klangfarbe und so dass
die natürlich ausgeprägter ist als bei
leuten die sich vielleicht erst kurze
zeit kennen aber das kann natürlich auch
wie die faust aufs auge passen und nach
einem jahr macht uns schon gute musik
zusammen das kann natürlich auch ganz
schnell gehen
aber bei uns ist eben sehr organische
struktur
bestimmt die man sich anhören können die
man nach außen geben konnte bestimmt
fünf sechs sieben jahre also natürlich
haben wir unsere sachen auch schon
früher gefeiert so den ersten track den
wir aufgenommen haben haben wir schon
gedacht wir sind die krassesten von
allen natürlich aber und aber natürlich
im nachhinein ist man schlauer und merkt
an ok das war schon ziemlich trotz der
wir da gemacht haben aber so ist das so
man fängt an und das eine der
wichtigsten regeln überhaupt im leben
und das gilt für die musik genauso wie
für alle anderen lebensbereiche ist dran
bleiben man muss einfach dranbleiben und
weiter machen
es gibt natürlich einen oder anderen der
nicht peilt dass er vielleicht aufhören
sollte lieber das kann natürlich auch
passieren dass man sich verrennt aber
wenn man mit viel leidenschaft an etwas
dran geht und bereit ist zu investieren
zu lernen zu arbeiten fleißig zu sein
und irgendwann wird man besser im
regelfall auch wirklich einige jahre
auch ein comedian der brauch sieben
jahre
ich glaub auch in der wirtschaft und
unternehmen aufbaus dann ist so die
halbwertszeit bis man zum ersten mal
rentabel wird drei bis fünf jahre ist
ganz normal also die selten also den
seltensten fällen hat man eine idee und
ist über nacht millionär siehe apple wie
lange haben sie gebraucht um
durchzubrechen sie haben am anfang ein
riesenerfolg genaue runter gekracht und
dann aber du siehst du das ist also das
sind erfolgsgeschichten sind nie nur
straight
was für ein verhältnis habt ihr was seid
ihr seid der kollegen seit der freunde
seit der brüder wie würdet ihr das mit
wie würdet ihr werfen nennen oder was
gehört dazu eine gute musiker beziehung
zu haben
also ich würde sagen dass wir
irgendetwas zwischen all dem sind so
also wir haben eine sehr enge
menschliche beziehung zueinander
das maximales vertrauen da ja wenn du
willst kannst du hast als bruderschaft
bezeichnen auf jeden fall warum nicht
mehr burger vom motto geht nicht
doch wer geht mir sehr offen sagt immer
es nicht witzig und
nervt einfach nur ab aber geht schon
also dass eigentlich der kreative bist
du und der nerv nur genau so sehe ich
das ja ja das klärende kind das auf dem
boden stand aber warum seid ihr denn so
produktiv also was ist dann ja keine
andere trainiert dass wir können uns
halt auch einfach sagen wir können uns
halt einfach sagen wenn wir uns offen
sagt dann sage ich mach mal kopf zu
jetzt oder umgekehrt
und dann ist gut an streitet man sich
halt auch kurz das gehört natürlich auch
dazu und dann hofft man sich halt
einfach wieder zusammen so wir haben so
alle großen streits schon hinter uns
sagt was war der größte
das nie aber das war nicht der gleiche
typ für uns interessant ist aber keine
ahnung sollte rein wo sich freuen sich
wo man sich um einen schlecht behandeln
erfüllt hat oder so und so keine ahnung
aber das ist so jugend geschichten halt
einfach wie jede wie jede junge männer
freundschaft jungen freundschaft das
halt so durchlebt und dann ist auch
irgendwann wieder gut nur dann wird man
älter und erwachsen und kann über die
dinge sprechen auf einmal kann sich an
artikulieren und dann räumt man die
dinge im idealfall halt aus der welt
wenn ihr jetzt sagt er
fünf sechs sieben jahre war das was
gesagt trotz aber sagen wir mal nicht so
optimal
wo hat es begonnen zu funktionieren weil
das auch in eurer zusammenarbeit ein
besonderer moment wo es irgendwie klick
gemacht hat also ich würde sagen es war
so dass wir uns in der zeit lang nicht
mehr gesehen hatten und dann haben wir
uns nach einem jahr oder so wieder
getroffen und in der zwischenzeit keine
musik zusammen gemacht und dann komm
rennt oder gar keine musik die so jeder
hat für sich so passieren weiter vor
sich hin gemacht man natürlich die
leidenschaft immer da ist und man hat
natürlich immer bock irgendwie und dann
haben wir uns wieder getroffen und
gesagt komm so ich habe mich
weiterentwickelt ich mich auch lassen
wir jetzt was richtiges machen was man
jetzt versuchen ernsthaft das ganze zu
machen und natürlich auch gereift und
man hat gesehen so okay gibt internet
und man kann damit nicht nur
wechsel auf pornoseiten sondern man kann
auch sich mit etwas sinnvollem
beschäftigen und versuchen geld zu und
dann haben wir halt versuchte
professionell daran zu machen und das
war so der startschuss im letzten anlauf
den wir genommen haben sozusagen haben
gesagt okay das professionalisieren das
ganze und versuchen ernsthaft
erfolgreich zu werden und das war der
der bruch punkt so vorführte
das war die initialzündung mitgenommen
was macht das professionelle aus wo ist
der schritt was macht man anders wenn
man professionell wird was man sie jetzt
im biet machen oder bei der produktion
wo ist der schritt was war anders zudem
weil wir vorher produziert habt was man
dass professor eigentlich 40 gar nichts
gemein weil ich damals viele profis
produzieren im oder neben den gesang in
meinem schlafzimmer aus fast so wie wir
haben wir bis zur udo zirkus aufgemacht
also komplett alles im kleiderschrank
aufgenommen leider scheinen aber
ausstaffiert und ansonsten ja wir haben
auch kein studio gar nichts wir machen
alles wie gehabt wie zuvor
professionalität
also das heißt einfach bereit zu sein
opfer für die sache zu bringen das heißt
man stellt die mutter einfach nicht mehr
ganz hinten an und macht das nur noch
als hobby wenn man gerade zeit hat
sondern man sagt okay ich beschäftige
mich jetzt intensiv damit und ich guck
da sich vorgekommen dass er sich versuch
einer gewissen regelmäßigkeit zu
schreiben zu produzieren
konzepte für tricks entwickelt oder so
was das heißt einfach intensiver
arbeiten und dann natürlich heute auch
der schritt in die öffentlichkeit
das ist das ding so aber ehrlich gesagt
nicht aber man lernt halt so von mal zu
mal das erste radio interview was wir
jemals hatten war vielleicht noch
holpriger als wir
ja ich sag's war es war genau das
gleiche wie jetzt wird es routiniert gut
dann wünsche ich natürlich mit
interviews egal merkt man vielleicht ich
lasse jetzt gleich noch
man braucht wenn man etwas erfolgreich
machen will egal was muss man halt
fleißig sein und man muss arbeiten also
man keiner braucht zu glauben so wenn er
jetzt musik macht und gerne erfolgreich
sein will dass man einfach nur geil
track machen muss und dann ist man der
king so das läuft nicht
du kannst zehn geile tracks machen 100
geile tracks machen die allerbesten und
wenn du das nicht richtig nach außen
transportiert kriegst dann bringt das
gar nichts also man muss es gehört
einfach auch viel arbeit dazu es ist so
ein großteil talent natürlich dann ist
aber ein ganz ganz überwiegender teil
vielleicht sogar einfach arbeit und die
bereitschaft sich den arsch aufzureißen
für irgendwas so man kriegt es nicht
geschenkt egal wie gut man es heißt auch
wenn ihr gut seid das ist nur die halbe
miete jungs ihr müsst fleißig sein
darüber hinaus disziplin ist eine
wichtige angelegenheit jemand der extrem
diszipliniert ist der wird es nicht
schaffen auf dauer erfolgreich zu sein
vielleicht vielleicht klappt mal so ein
glueck sling zum lucky punch kann jeder
mal setzen aber dauerhaft erfolgreich zu
sein und sich zu etablieren und sich auf
einem gewissen niveau zu halten dazu
gehört einfach konstanz und die das geht
mit dem kopf also statt party genau
statt party lieber mal genau so war das
bei uns auch so als wir als der als
viele freunde von uns damals oft
wechseln saufen was weiß ich was machen
waren wir zu hause und haben uns mit
musik beschäftigt das ist einfach so
also musik erleben
also für uns ist es natürlich nicht
langweilig weil es das spaß macht was
wir machen weil wir das lieben aber es
ist auf jeden fall wenn man wenn man
erfolgreich sein will es gibt ja auch
leute die für die entscheiden sich sie
wollen damit nicht kommerziell
erfolgreich sein ist auch in ordnung
aber wenn man das auf einem gewissen
niveau betreiben möchte und sagen will
ok im idealfall kann ich davon leben
dann muss man dafür ist dass im
endeffekt arbeit wie andere arbeit auch
das gehört auch dazu
vielleicht sogar ein bisschen mehr weil
man keine festen also es gibt keine mann
ist im endeffekt selbstständig und es
gibt keine festen arbeitszeiten ich kann
mir keinen urlaub nehmen und so weiter
wenn album ansteht dann fahren wir von
termin zu termin und reisen tausende von
kilometern ab innerhalb weniger wochen
fand quer durch deutschland und auch so
natur ist eine sache die macht unfassbar
viel spaß aber das ist doch unfassbar
viel stress und anstrengungen und ja wie
gesagt das ist alles nicht so mal eben
nebenher gemacht so das kostet schon
kraft einfach an alle da draußen die
denken wieso retten ist so leicht dass
wir von mikrofon stehen ein paar reime
runter reimen wir haben die erfahrung
gemacht dass es das nicht ist vielleicht
gibt es jemanden in der szene der er
sagt bei mir ist alles ganz easy ich
brauche gar nichts zu machen
alles läuft von selbst aber ich zweifle
mal stark daran dass das so ist so
stellmann die allermeisten die
erfolgreich sind arbeiten genauso hart
wie wir das okay dann wünsche ich euch
danach viel erfolg habt danke weiter
hart arbeitet ok danke werden wir machen